MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this section, we look
at electroweak unification.
So the aim is to
combine the weak
and the electromagnetic
interactions.
The issues we can
see here are first,
the strength of the
interactions are very different.
This can be
mitigated by the fact
that we have heavy
gauge bosons involved,
and we have seen
our heavy particles
as being used as mediators
to kind of change
the strength of the interaction.
So this might not
be a big issue.
The second problem is that
the structure of the coupling
is very different.
We have seen for QED that
they are the vector coupling
and for weak
interaction that they
are the vector-axial coupling.
This 1 minus gamma 5 is
vector minus axial coupling.
So one way to
mitigate this problem
is to simply absorb this 1 minus
gamma 5 term in the definition
of the particle spinors.
And I have to warn you,
this is a little misleading.
And I think that led also
to some of the confusion we
had in the class before.
So what we are doing here
simply is, we take our spinor,
and we project out with
the 1 minus gamma 5 term
what the left-handed
component of this spinor is.
This is just a projection
and the definition of this.
And we can do this for
antiparticles as well as
for the right-handed
components as well.
Good.
So now we can look
at the current again.
And we look at this weak current
that you have seen you can
write as our antineutrino here,
gamma mu times 1 minus gamma 5
1/2 times e.
Now, if we now define our
particles which gamma matrices,
we find that this
simplifies quite a bit,
because we now find the current,
which can be simply written
as a vector current.
So we mitigated
this quite nicely.
So what now happens to our
electromagnetic interaction
here?
So we have an electron
coupling to a photon.
We can project out a
right-handed and left-handed
component, and then we have
to add them together again.
When we do this, you
find that this component
of the left-handed
component, or the current
corresponding to the
left-handed particle
and the current corresponding
to the right-handed particle.
There's no mixed
term here because
of the way gamma matrices or
gamma 5 matrices multiply.
So that's nice.
This also explains why the
helicity is not changed in QED.
You basically see
this from the algebra
involved in those equations.
Good.
So far, we haven't
done anything.
We have just changed
the notation.
So we can go one step further.
And we use the
concepts we introduced
when we talked about QCD
or the strong isospin.
And since we can nicely
describe those currents here
of those particles,
we can maybe see
if we can write a
neutrino and an electron
as part of a duplet.
And when we do this, we
rewrite the currents,
the positively charged and
the negatively charged current
as simply the left-handed
components of those duplets.
We introduced a new matrix
here, tau plus and tau minus.
And they're simply combinations
of tau 1 and tau 2,
which are, in fact,
the Pauli matrix.
This is just a
relabelling as well.
So there's a lot of relabelling
going on, not to confuse you.
But we have simply
written this current
as positively
charged weak current
and negatively
charged current, where
we rotate a neutrino into
an electron or an electron
into a neutrino using
the weak interaction.
Great.
So now we can write
this current here
as the third component
of this current.
And we see when we write
down the third component
of this current
using tau 3 here,
we find that something looks--
something which looks
like a neutral current.
So this is something like
a neutral current, where
we have a neutrino
coupling to a neutrino
and a left-handed
electron coupling
to a left-handed electron,
on a vertex vector
[?] where there's an
interaction that was going on.
This is not quite
the full story yet.
Let me remind you
about the definition
we used also in
isospin, which is
the Gell-Mann-Nishijima
equation, which connected
the electric charge to the
isospin and the strangeness
of the particle.
And we do the very same thing.
We have an isospin component
and a so-called hypercharge
component.
It's similar to the
strangeness we had before.
And Q is the electric charge
of the particle involved.
And so with this, we
can now define an iso--
a hyperspin current,
which is given as 2 times
the electromagnetic
current minus 2 times
the third component of the--
third component of
the weak current here.
And so now we find
interesting effects here.
There's a new component
which also couples
to right-handed particles.
So the missing part here--
some of you might have
seen this already--
is this neutral current
in the upper equation
didn't connect or didn't
have a contribution
from right-handed particle.
And since there's
right-handed electron which
coupled to Z boson,
there needed to be
this kind of additional term.
So now we have a
current which includes
the right-handed
particles as well.
So that's great.
We can generalize this
by writing those duplets
for all particles we know.
There's an additional
kind of caveat here.
We haven't talked
about this too much.
We have to consider the fact
that mass eigenstates are not
really the same eigenstates
which participate
in the weak interaction.
Right now we can ignore this.
We'll later come back
to this question.
And then we can write
the three components
of our isospin current and our
hypercharge current as well.
Note that this EM current here
is our electromagnetic current.
Good.
So now we rewrote this, and
we find somehow very close
a consistent picture.
We find that there
is a charged current,
and then there is
a neutral current
in the weak interaction.
But what we actually
wanted to do
is combine the weak
interaction and
electromagnetic interaction.
Now, let's look at this
again and start over again.
So we have an
isospin current here,
which copies to the
three components--
the triplet, the
isospin triplet.
So this is a W1, W2, W3 triplet.
And then we have
the singlet here
which couples to
the hypercharge.
Very good.
So now, if I try to identify
now components which we already
know the first
thing we can do, we
have to make sure that we
find our W plus and W minus
bosons again.
And they're simply
linear combinations
of the W1's and the W2's.
And then the next
thing I have to do
is I have to find my
electromagnetic interaction.
And we can do that by binding
this A-- this is the photon--
as a linear combination
of the third component
of our triplet, isospin
triplet, and our singlet.
And what you see here
is that there's actually
mixing going on.
So we basically rotate those
with this mixing angle, which
we already introduced,
sine omega weak
mixing angle theta omega--
sorry, theta W.
So we find that the
photon can be made out
of a mixing of the third
component of the isospin
triplet and the
singlet component B mu.
And similarly, we
can find the Z boson
as the other component in this
mixing, the other state we
find in this mixing.
The way we find
those mixings here
is through the couplings
we already know,
that we find this
omega g times sine
theta W is equal to g
prime cosine omega W.
And that's equal to the
electromagnetic coupling.
And then similarly, we
find a solution for gz.
So what we have seen now
is that apparently we
are able to combine the weak and
the electromagnetic interaction
by mixing--
by introducing the weak isospin
and by mixing isospin triplet
components with a
singlet component.
And so we find a
picture which is
consistent with the W plus, a W
minus photon, and the Z boson.
So that's very nice.